what's interesting about florida and i
wanted to give you a chance to talk
about this because florida ranks 27th in
the nation for per capita deaths from
the virus
some states that shut down obviously and
had all those mandates new york
michigan massachusetts all have higher
death rates
do you think it's possible when you look
up back on this that it may be that
desantis did some things right
well aaron i think it would be fair to
say
that governor desantis did a few things
right
he did a lot of things wrong like when
he didn't
do everything i told him to do for the
last
year of slowing the spread but
i think he did a few things right he uh
probably brushed his teeth in the
morning
probably tied his shoes before he left
the house
are there are there some things when you
look at florida that you that you think
that he did get
right oh absolutely he had
democrats as mayors so that was
excellent and they did every single
thing i
told them to do so that was very very
good and important
for slowing the spread and of course
even though a guy like ron desantis
maybe does a very bad job
at least you still have good old dr
fauci
wear the mask sheep
[Music]
[Music]
you